understanding the emotional core at the
center of interstellar requires
understanding how time dilation Works
once the crew of the endurance reaches
Miller's Planet full of treacherous
waves it is assumed the audience
understands this concept but how exactly
does the time dilation make sense in
interstellar the explanation the movie
gives is that a difference in
gravitational force causes time to move
at different speeds on different planets
this dilation effect is accelerated when
in the case of Millers the planet is
orbiting a black hole as the force of
gravity increases time moves at an
accelerated Pace while Coop and his crew
only spend a few hours crash landed on
Miller's Planet 23 years have passed on
Earth according to scientist Neil
deGrasse Tyson this detail of
interstellar is a scientific phenomenon
that exists for real this can be proven
by Einstein's equation of general
relativity that's relativity folks